make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing with this trend of
uploading content for the sake of giving
you guys stuff that you've asked for
because my cellphone Mariah are packing
this week we're gonna be doing Avengers
vs. x-men right these are pretty simple
they're pretty fun but these are the we
already did The Avengers vs. x-men main
story this one's gonna be the vs. series
right so for those you guys who don't
know
during Avengers vs. x-men it was one of
the most fun stories that Marvel did but
over the course of the entire 12 issues
they gave us these vs. series right and
they were little like quick little
stories right each one or each versus
battle is like eight pages long so it's
not super lengthy but it was basically
just fanservice is really all it was
right it was almost kind of like a
return to the old Ron Mars Marvel vs. DC
stories right where it was like you know
Marvel Comics vs. DC Comics and then
fans would pick which characters once
you'd get Wonder Woman versus storm and
the winner of that match who I think was
Wonder Woman who is based on who the
fans chose right the majority ruled in
that particular instance this was much
the same way not really in terms of the
fans choosing but insofar as it's just
fanservice and the first one that we get
to see here is magneto versus Iron Man
but here's a funny thing about it like
as cool as this fight is the one that
we're gonna do tomorrow
the one on gambit versus versus Captain
America and a Spider Man vs the
unstoppable Colossus or like way better
they are infinitely better now off the
bat like right off the bat you're kind
of like why is this even a fight in the
first place like a man in a metal suit
versus a guy who can control metal this
fight should be dunzo right this why
should be like like five seconds long
right Iron Man's like I'm gonna get you
magneto maybe it was like no you're not
either and then just uses his powers and
then fireman gets crushed into a tin can
and he's destroyed and that's basically
the end of him but it's cool right
Marvel doesn't really use the easy way
out when it comes to these stories and
that's why it's so interesting right so
this one takes place during during issue
number two right in the middle of issue
number two when everything pops off
between the Avengers and the x-men the
way this plays out is is it's kind of
funny there's this kind of comment that
goes on right you know my man just kind
of feels like dude like I can feel like
what man I didn't feel this guy's power
right like I didn't feel what this guy
can do and at the same time magneto is
kind of chiming in and is like this guy
is full of recklessness right this guy
is arrogant if you really believe that
in a metal suit he can somehow defeat me
he's not only arrogant he's an idiot
right because this guy cannot defeat me
it's kind of crazy well then what ends
up happening is like magneto goes to
realize that he's not wearing metal that
he cannot control the suit of Iron Man
and why is because I am man is wearing
carbon nanotubes now this is a cool
thing and this is one of those things
that goes into like all the different
types of armor that Iron Man has right
because over the years Iron Man is a
mass these different suits of armor for
a wide array of different purposes some
of them are for interstellar travel
going into space and traveling lengthy
vince's distances rise from one side of
the galaxy to the other but then he also
has stealthy Iron Man suits suits that
are actually invisible to the human eye
right like suits that have all these
different kinds of abilities and all
these different things having a suit in
preparation for facing off against the
x-men we have to believe that Iron Man
has all these various suits right he's
got suits designed to combat Magneto's
powers of a magnetism
he's got suits that are designed to
combat Charles Xavier telepathy suits
that Cyclops can't punch through with
his optic beams whatever the case is
he's got all these different suits that
are designed to to essentially get the
upper hand on virtually any one of the
x-men and that's exactly what happens
here right he kind of uses to himself
right he starts talking about something
that Mike Tyson said everybody's got a
plan until they get punched in the mouth
and then they don't have a plan anymore
right and it's kind of funny because
magneto is like oh man dude your suits
not made of metal whatever am I going to
do is I lift this 70 ton tower off the
ground and throw it on you and it's kind
of funny because in this moment magneto
display some humerus right because in
his responses it's kind of like okay
we're finished
you know like stay down stark like
you're basically done and then from
there like stark pops back up again and
then just starts emitting all these anti
magnetism weapons right these magnets
are these weapons that are designed to
dampen the powers of magneto but here's
the funny thing about this Magneto's
powers are extreme and it's one of these
things that you can't really prepare for
when you're Iron Man you can do the best
you can but it's one of these things
where you've got to be able to face off
against him in order to be able to
overpower him and at the same time over
the years by whatever manner and
whatever means editorial decisions
whether the case is the powers of
magneto have amplify they've grown over
ton and it's one of these cool things
because what you end up getting is
basically him just kind of having this
this sort of electromagnetic force field
around him and then in turn just making
its way toward Iron Man now one thing to
bear in mind here and this is very
important is Iron Man is using repulsor
beams but his stance is that these
repulsor beams are useless against
magneto shield right there's no real way
that they can basically overpower
magneto shield but it's almost kind of
like they had themselves in a momentary
stalemate at the moment and the reason
why is because with magneto you
his concentration using his powers to
create a shield this design to basically
keep the repulsors from getting through
this takes a lot of energy right because
the repulsors are exceedingly powerful
what this does is it prevents magneto
from using his powers in other forms
namely issuing a blanket EMP and this is
one of the first things people would
have asked if magneto cannot control
Iron Man suit but Iron Man suit still
runs on electricity
it runs on some form of electricity then
why not just just like EMP Iron Man
right just like shudders shut his suit
down and that's basically yet and then
he ends up going the way that he did
when it was the Punisher versus the
Marvel Universe those you guys should
have read that story I was messed up
there was this great big huge virus that
well we won't go too deep into it I've
got a video series on it but it was like
this virus that broke out or something
like that long story short in the middle
of it all I am an suit shuts down and it
basically turns into a tomb he can't get
out of it he basically dies and his Iron
Man suit like dies of starvation and
it's crazy because there's one point
where the Punisher walks by and he's
like they said it was three days before
the screaming finally stopped and it was
like damn man like that sucks dude have
your suit of armor turned into a tomb
that you can't get out of but
nonetheless it's one of these things
where he's basically constantly emitting
these repulsors in order to force
magneto to keep his shield up if magneto
shield is up then he cannot issue an EMP
I suppose it's one of these ways for
Ironman to kind of force a stalemate to
a degree while this happens what he does
is he taps into Jupiter now this is one
of the things understand here ever since
the events of of Karen Gillan's Ironman
run and even before curing Guillen's on
a man run when he was part of guardians
of the galaxy by a man had basically
tapped into using various devices out
there across the solar system right
because when he went from Strictly being
just an earth-based hero to being a hero
that started charting the spaceways and
getting out there and seeing what was
there minute turned into of course well
let's find a way to basically you know
utilize that kind of stuff and so what
he ends up doing is tapping into some
satellites around Jupiter now this is
where the comic book key element comes
in right it's just it's comic books go
with it right if you're Neil deGrasse
Tyson you're probably just like actually
the science behind this thing with these
particular equations and these things
that I have written on this white board
here say that this is not possible right
I mean if you're going that direction
sure but like it's comic books run with
it what he ends up doing is basically
tapping into the electromagnetic
spectrum of Jupiter and then in turn
handling that energy into himself and
it's kind of fun it's kind of a funny
thing right because literally what he
says is the magnetic field of Jupiter is
ten times what earth is essentially
amplifying himself up with
energy that's ten times what magneto
normally has and then in turn just sort
of channeling that energy into himself
and then just blasting magneto with a
huge amount of energy now this does not
mean that that Iron Man has in turn able
to control and use the electromagnetic
spectrum
it means he's just channeling all this
energy into himself and then blasting
magneto with it now from there it
basically turns into Magneto literally
ripping the satellites apart from the
sky bringing it back down and then
sending them flying directly ad at Iron
Man which of course sends him on the
defensive and then you get a kind of
hand-to-hand skirmish but it's only for
a moment right this actual hand-to-hand
conflict is for like half a page it's
literally Iron Man and magneto charging
at each other going to attack each other
and then suddenly magneto basically
deviates and the reason for that is
because his mind gets caught by the
arrival of the Phoenix why the fact that
the Phoenix is coming here and he
basically senses an entire civilization
basically being wiped out and what it
does is it creates just enough of a
momentary distraction that Ironman gets
the upper hand now here's the question
that I want to know from you guys here's
a question that I'm that I'm curious
about had that not happened how do you
not been distracted would magneto have
won well man you don't have managed to
get the upper hand on Tony Stark because
in this instance magneto got his own
powerup right literally using like solar
panels and amplifying himself right kind
of having this this sort of armor suit
over his body that basically channels
like the power of the Sun and then in
turn attacking Stark with it right so
he's already amped up but with him
getting the upper hand the way he did
had that not happened had he not been
distracted would Iron Man have gotten
the upper hand that's my question and I
feel like the answer to that question is
yes but what this does is it switches
over to the next story right again these
are pretty short right so the next one
goes into namor the sub-mariner versus
Ben Grimm now this is a pretty easy
fight to overlook but it's a pretty easy
fight to look at and just be like well
this is dumb but here's the thing
namor the sub-mariner so here's the
thing you guys have to understand right
nimma the Submariner does not get his
due that's what you need to understand
let me say some never the Submariner if
he's written by the right writer do he
is a hoss dude he's an absolute demon
and it's one of these things where like
I'll tend Namor Submariner fans out
there will agree like they'll tell you
that right
he's definitely underrated and he's not
really written adequately and it's true
right I mean he's he's not really
written effectively more often than not
right like nine times out of ten he's
just like a guy who's there but like if
you go when you read Hickman's offenders
the New Avengers he's written amazingly
well if you go when you read the old
Fantastic Four stories for the comic
book
hipsters out there if you go when you
read the old John Byrne Fantastic Four
stories he's written insanely well
especially when he's trying to bang
Susan storm all the time but it's one of
these these these funny things right
because in this fight that goes down of
course Ben Grimm ends up in a fight with
with name with a submariner in name wars
domain now for the most part name war
starts to get the upper hand on Van grin
and the reason why is because name were
super strong he's a really really
powerful character in his own right and
getting the upper hand on Ben Grimm is
no small thing because Ben Grimm's gone
toe-to-toe with some pretty heavy
hitters right he's fought the Hulk on
multiple occasions he's fought Thor he's
fought juggernaut most of those fights
he's lost
but he's gone against like some pretty
heavy hitters and been able to hold his
own for more than a little bit right so
because of that like having named were
faced off against him in that way it's
pretty impressive but the other part of
this is there a kind of trading like as
much verbal blows as they are physical
blows right like Ben Grimm is like dude
you're not gonna get with Susan storm so
I don't even know why you've been trying
all this time like she's not gonna bang
you man like you're in the friend zone
at best at worst you're an enemy in
which case you're never gonna get that
girl between the sheets and it is kind
of a little bit of a moral blow to like
name of the Sun Mary like it's a shots
of the pride right because that was kind
of the thing that was going on but the
funny thing about this is like seemingly
out of nowhere this colossal fish right
this giant monster fish shows up and
literally named when the Submariner
grabs it and throws it at Ben Grimm now
this is one of the more awesome moments
right because Ben Grimm interned like
anchors his way onto the front of this
fish grabs his two biggest teeth and
then just Yanks it out of its mouth and
sends the fish crashing into the ground
and then grabs the two teeth heads
towards Namor and just pins him to the
ground and leaves it's one of the
coolest things I guess one of the best
finishes took like a fight right just
being like John you know and it's like
because Ben Grimm is kind of breaking a
sweat and getting clobbered a bit but
like by no means is this a fight where
he's like pushing himself to the limit
right as one of the cool things about it
right it's not like one of these things
where he's like barely making it and he
just kind of got this Hail Mary with
this giant fish that came out of nowhere
but it's cool right like each one of
these verses stories are really really
intriguing right because in the next one
like we said the beginning of the video
in the next one we're gonna get into
gambit versus Captain America and if I'm
being honest with you guys I think
that's actually the best one I think
gambit versus Captain America is the
best out of all the vs. matches it's
like the coolest one that one in
spider-man vs. unstoppable Colossus
which is pretty amazing but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are no year to
comments explain and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob port if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you